This video, we'll see a few
concepts related to optimization,
which are going to help us understand
how optimization behaves in training
neural networks and,
uh,
give us ideas for how we could actually
improve optimization of neural networks.
Okay.
So we've seen that neural network training
is essentially based on optimizing a,
an average loss or a regularized
average lost if loss,
if we have a regular riser. And, uh, what
we've done is that, is that we've used a,
uh, known, uh,
a known optimization methods to cast
a great in dissent and optimize that
average loss,
uh,
to perform training to fit on your
own network to our training data. So,
uh, what about optimizing this
optimization problem? Is it a,
is it well behaved? What properties
does it have? Unfortunately,
for neural nets, uh, it's, uh,
the optimization problem is,
uh, not particularly
easy. Uh, for one thing,
there isn't a single global optimum to
the optimization problem with trying to
solve, uh, minimizing the average
training loss or the average, uh,
regularize training loss. Uh, we
can see this because we can compete,
we can permute all the hidden
units along with their connections.
And we actually don't
change the value of f of x,
the output value of the neural
network. It hasn't changed at all. Uh,
and so this means that there isn't a
single unique solution that corresponds to
the best training error we can
achieve with a neural network.
Any permutation of the hidden units
will result in the same function,
the same solution.
Okay.
Uh, so in that sense we can say that
the parameters of a hidden layer,
uh, are not identifiable. Okay.
There we can't identify if their data
set was truly generated from a neural
network.
We can't identify what's the
actual weights of each unit.
We can't identify actually the order in
which these hidden units, uh, were, uh,
organizing the original neural network.
But that's not such a bad thing.
As long as we get the right function
f of x, uh, the right predictions,
then we'd be happy with that.
However,
also the optimization problem is known
as a non convex optimization problem,
uh,
and that even if they were identifiable,
that would still be a lot of
local minimum or local minima. So,
uh,
the optimization problem,
instead of looking something like this
where we have a sort of bullshit convex
function where there's only
a single global optimum,
and if we followed the gradient
steps, then eventually we would, uh,
necessarily converge to
The kobold optimum. Uh,
we actually have a function
which has a lot of local,
potentially a lot of local
minima where for instance,
we have a region here which locally looks
likable. But if we got outside of it,
we could find that there's another
region which has a better solution.
So this region here would correspond.
And actually this value
here that's optimizes the
function locally here is known
as a local minima and also other less
obvious but still fairly annoying,
uh, properties that we can find
and optimization, optimizing,
optimizing neural networks,
a known as plateaus.
So these would be regions where
the function is essentially flat,
is very close to just a flat line.
Uh,
if you think of the stochastic
gradient descent algorithm,
what it would be doing there is, or the
just in general gradient descent a here,
well it would follow the grain and the
grain and because the function is almost
flat is very close to zero.
So we make very,
very small steps here as
it's optimizing the function.
And so,
uh,
because you don't get to see the whole
function where you're optimizing this,
you only see the progress of the training
error because it doesn't change a lot.
You might think, oh, I'm
close to convergence and uh,
maybe you'll stop before you
actually reach this part here,
which will drastically improve the error.
And so these regions here can mean that.
So the plateau here is as long it might
be so long that for the amount of time
you are willing to optimize
your neural net, uh,
you might actually never
get out of the plateau.
So that's another thing that we
sometimes see in neural network and, uh,
that are issues you need to
think about for designing, uh,
different potentially better training
algorithms for neural networks.
Um, so just keep in mind that
we're optimizing neural nets.
We are not guaranteed
to find a global Optima.
We might just find a local optimum.
And uh,
and also it,
even if the training or doesn't move much,
it might just be that you're on the
plateau and that eventually you'll,
you'll be reaching a region where the
training air will drastically improve.
So if you see that your training error
is moving very slowly and then eventually
dropping a lot,
this is something that's normal.
It's necessarily a bug in your code
that just might happen because the,
the function is noncombat sin
has long plateaus like these.
Now let's see these properties in action.
We'll look at a demo that was
provided by Andrei carpathy.
Uh, and it's going to illustrate
this a property of local optimum.
That is the fact that if we take a neural
network and initialize it at different
values, we might converge to different
local Optima. So if we look back at this,
uh, cartoon case here, if we are an
initialized gradient descent here,
it would eventually converge
to that optimum. Whereas here,
it would actually have converged
to slowly move to that optimum.
So let's see this in action. Uh, so here,
this is a classification problem where
we have these dots here that are in one
class. And then these dots here that
are another class and that this is the,
uh, uh, decision, uh, a
decision boundary for,
uh, the castigation that's performed
by eight, this neural network.
And here we have the training error.
We see it's still going down a little bit,
but it's, uh, it's mostly converged.
Now let's see what happens
if I reinitialize the neural
net with different, uh,
random weights. Now let's get to
what it convergence. Does it change?
Does it still have this shape or will
they have a fairly different chain?
Okay,
sorry.
It's retraining.
And we see now that the shape has changed
a little bit. So here we have, uh,
this partier used to be not
associated with that class,
but with this class and that this
part here also is a bit less flat.
Um, interesting. That's initialize. Again,
this looks a little bit more like
before we've seem to have come,
it seems to be converging
to similar region. Uh,
let's do that again, a little bit about,
this is starting to be quite different.
So we get a big region here
associated with that class.
So as we see with different initial,
uh, different initialization,
so different random seeds essentially
that generate the random numbers and
utilize the weights.
We can get fairly different solutions.
But of this is that it always at least
perfectly classify as the training set.
But a new examples which say might
lie here, different neural nets,
my life provide different answers
depending on the initialization.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, I've also talked about
grading the sand and I've, uh, you know,
thus far just said that, you know,
it works fine and it's a, uh,
optimizes the training error. But
what about convergence? So, uh,
what are the conditions that we need to
guarantee that it will eventually, uh,
uh, converge to the true solution
instead of, uh, at home point,
uh, reach, uh,
reach a value in maybe cycle
and never actually zoom,
zoom in on the actual solution?
The two conditions we need is that a,
so alpha t,
which is the learning rate for the
teeth, uh, update of the neural nets, uh,
parameters.
So the sum of all the learning waits for
all iterations needs to divergent needs
to go to infinity,
but the sum of the square of the
learning rates needs to converge.
So that needs to be a converging some.
So notice that in the case
where Alpha is constant,
then this would, uh, this
was actually a diverged.
And so a constant learning rate does
not guarantee that stochastic gradient
descent will eventually converge.
Okay.
And I'll talk about why this
isn't always a bad problem,
but if you do want to satisfy
these conditions, then uh,
what we'll want to, uh, you know,
the few decreasing, uh, strategies.
One that's very common is this one.
So we just take an initial learning rate.
So that's our regular
alphabet hyper parameter.
And then we divided by one plus the
number of updates we've done so far,
times a decreasing constant
or decrease constant, uh,
which is another hyper parameter.
Now that we need to select a,
this is another strategy which has been
proposed in the literature and it has
certain properties.
So we divide just by the number
of either update so far, but uh,
to the, uh, my decrease
constant parameter.
And in this case we have to satisfy
this condition. Uh, and, uh,
looking at the literature,
there are other proposals.
This one is probably one of
the most popular in general.
It's actually a good idea to keep a fixed
learning rate like we've seen in the
originally I saw a fixed
Alpha for uh, a few, uh,
the first few updates with their first
few epochs and then eventually start
decreasing it. Uh, so we make
a lot of, I guess initially,
and then we start decreasing the
learning rate so that it can zoom in and
converge to a good value.
Now,
the reason that we might still use a
constant alpha is that remember that we
don't necessarily care about optimizing
perfectly the training error because
what we care about this generalization,
where we care about this performing
well on the test set. And so, uh,
it might be that before
we get to get, uh, to, uh,
come close to the best training error
configuration of the neural net,
we actually weigh into a region
that has a lot of our fittings.
So in the curve that we've seen where
we have the validation set that's like
this, the generalization performance in
the training set, it might be that, um,
you know, if we get to convergence,
we actually going to get very,
very bad a value on the validation set,
a lot of over fitting.
So because we don't care about optimizing
the training set perfectly and we
mainly care about getting a
good generalization error,
as long as the learning rate
does not too big, then, uh,
we very well might stop learning with
early stopping way before the algorithm,
uh, uh, starts cycling and not
converging to particular lab value.
So in practice, as long as
Alpha is not too big, then,
uh, we will, uh, early stopping.
We'll have a stop training way before
we get any problems in terms of
convergence. Okay. So, um, unless
you actually for some reason really,
really care about getting a
very good training error. Uh,
if you think that actually
you're not going to overfit,
then you tend to almost be
in the overfitting situation.
A constant Alpha is often something
that works well in practice.
Other, uh, variations on a gradient
descent that we can see in the literature.
Um, sometimes people use what's
called minibatch learning.
So a mini batch is just a set of maybe
a hundred examples that we've picked
randomly from the training
set and idea is to, uh,
instead of using the gradients over a
single example to perform our update as in
a stochastic gradient descent,
we just use the average gradient of all
the examples in my mini batch of enemy.
Minibatch will often be about 128
examples, something like that.
So the average gradient is the same
thing as taking the grain of the average
regularized loss or the
average loss on the mini batch.
And the idea is that this is going to
be because we're taking the average of a
bunch of, uh, uh, example,
we're going to get a more accurate
estimate of the true gradient of the,
uh, uh, average, um, uh,
of the average a loss.
I shouldn't say risk here.
It's a more accurate
estimate of the average,
uh, loss gradient. And, uh,
one advantage in terms of computations
is that if we are working with mini
batches, then we can write the uh, uh,
forward prop and backdrop, uh,
operations. So backpropagation,
uh,
using some matrix matrix operations,
matrix multiplications and performing
Matrix Matrix multiplications is going to
be much more efficient with
certain libraries like blast blast,
which are just a very well known low
level library for performing a linear
Algebra operations. So Matrix,
Matrix multiplications,
I'm going to be much faster, uh,
with the library like blast then, uh,
performing 128 forward
propagation and backpropagation.
So performing all 128
grade him a computations
simultaneously with Matrix Matrix
operations will either procedure
which is much more efficient.
And that's because a library is like plus
our cash aware and I try to optimize,
uh, the memory access. Um, so, uh,
so yeah, I'll, I'll, I'll let you
look at the literature for you can,
you can do this.
So you can try to think about how we
can simultaneously compute gradients for
many examples by performing instead of
performing matrix vector operations and
like in regular backdrop performing
matrix, matrix multiplication. Um,
and other approach that's often use is
to instead of using the gradient of a
single example,
use an exponential average of gradients
as we perform a gradient descent.
So the uh,
direction for updating our parameters
for the teeth update could be in the
instead of just, and so this is for
the, uh, non non regularized loss.
Instead of just taking the gradient of
the loss for our current example will
also combine it with better,
which is going to be a hyper parameter
times d exponential average that,
uh,
I had computers at the previous updates.
So if you look at this formula,
you can see that at any time the update
direction is a combination of not just
the green and for the
current training example,
but also all the other previous
training examples which are in this, uh,
uh,
previous term here.
So this can be useful if we have
plateaus by, uh, moving more quickly,
getting a grade in
which is larger. Uh, uh,
if all the Graydon's always
pointed the same direction.
So intuitively it says if the
optimization is gaining momentum when we,
uh, when all the gradients are always
pointing in the same direction.
So it's as if we had a ball
that's moving on a slope,
which is always going straight.
So then the ball keeps going faster
and faster. It's gaining momentum.
So it's the same idea here, which might
allow us to move faster in the factors.
Funnily, I want to described
a different method for, uh,
in optimization for
optimizing the function. Uh,
it's called Newton's method.
And a,
it's an improved way of
optimizing a particular function.
And I want to mention it because we often
see a variance of that basic Newton's
method. In the papers on developing
better neural network training algorithms.
So I'll just give you a gist of the idea
behind Newton's method and this will
help you explore the literature on
more advanced neural network training
algorithms. So, uh, in
Newton Newton's method,
the idea is that if you
want to minimize something,
so imagine we have just a single example.
You want to minimize,
it's a training loss.
So the loss when given x as input,
uh, the neural network with a
particular set of parameters, uh,
predict something f of x and
a that's comparable or why.
So we want to optimize that loss.
Uh,
well one thing we could do is say,
well instead of optimizing this last,
which is non comebacks and complicated,
but just approximated around the point
which corresponds to the current value of
my parameter in my grading and descents,
uh,
migrant gradient descent procedure
in my training procedure.
And so what we could do is use a terrorist
series of expansion up to, uh, the, uh,
second order, a term where we
say that, well, around a t,
which is the current value of
mine, neural nets parameters. Well,
the value of the loss for any a set of
parameters data is going to be close to
that out. So it's going to
be approximately this value,
the value of the loss at
the current parameter,
plus the gradients at my current
parameter times the difference between the
theater, which is any potential value
of the weights of my neural net,
minus the current value of the weights.
And plus another term,
the second order term, which
involves a, uh, product, uh,
left tried product with instead of being
with the gradient, the, which is the,
um, uh, vector of all
first order derivatives,
it's going to be the Eshun,
which is the matrix of all second order,
uh, dairy dips. And, uh, so we get,
and then we get the left and
right product here with, uh,
the difference between the value of the
weights minus the current value of the
weights. And the idea behind
Newton's method is to say, well,
instead of optimizing the loss,
I'll actually optimize this.
Simpler function does
simpler approximation,
which comes from the dealer territories,
series expansion. Uh, and, uh,
what's nice is that the
second order version,
because it's a going to be quadratic,
we get actually optimizing perfectly.
So visually it means that they
mentioned that it had dysfunction here.
So imagine this line was a true function
and imagined that currently my weights.
So this would be a very simple function
with just a single parameter. Uh,
well I would just locally approximate
it with a quadratic function. Uh, sorry,
like this.
So I would just assume that this blue
line is actually well approximated by this
red line. And we see that
in these very close to, uh,
the current value of the parameter.
It's very,
the two lines are essentially on top of
each other, but as we go further away,
it's not as good. Um, but still locally
it would be a good approximation.
So it might be a good idea to just take
that approximation and move directly to,
it's a global minimum,
which would be around here.
And because it's a quadratic
function, we can actually, uh, uh,
find what's analytically,
what's the true solution.
So we can take the derivatives with
resect to our parameter of this a second
order approximation and set it
to zero. Uh, so this, you know,
taking the derivative of a,
with respect to theater of
this whole expression, uh, uh,
it gives me this and we can show that,
uh,
the solution then a curse sponsors.
So the new point would
actually be my current point,
my current parameter value multiply as,
sorry,
minus the inverse of the
session times degrading.
So notice that this is actually
quite similar to grading dissent.
Great in the sense,
instead of having a Hessian here,
just has a single scalar alpha.
Well, with Newton's method,
we get to actually take into account
the curvature of the function,
which is taking into account by the,
by the action.
So in particular from a function
which is very flat like this, um,
this term here, the inverse
session is going to be a quite big,
which means that if I was here, then
it would, um, this term being big,
it means that it would, I, I would,
uh, take a step that would be much, uh,
bigger. So I have a bigger
term times the same gradient.
Then if I had the function
with high curvature,
which would look something like this.
So at this point here,
because I have higher curvature,
this term would be smaller.
It would make a smaller smartest step.
So the nice thing is that if you
have a plateau like function here,
the Hessian allows us to make bigger
steps and so we might be able to move
faster into a plateau where as
if we end up very steep function,
then it's actually going to adapt and
take much smallest steps and updating the
parameters. Now, um, there
are still issues with this.
The first one is that, uh, well
this Hessian is a matrix of size,
number of parameters by a
number of parameters and
then there will network with
a few thousand units that easily
reaches and the millions of parameters.
So this would be 1 million
by 1 million, uh, matrix say,
and this is way too big to
even compute for every update.
And it's also way too big to just,
uh,
inverse as well because inverting the
matrix is also going to be very expensive.
So this is only practical.
They're very small neural network.
And also it's only we can apply
this update only if it's a,
at least locally comebacks. If the
function is locally convex, that is,
if at a point I compute the question,
uh, if it's locally convex
at that point, I mean, uh,
then the action is actually going to be
positive. Definite, which means that this,
this matrix here, this inverted
matrix is going to be a positive, uh,
definite. And, uh, so if I
locally add a function, which is,
uh, like this, then the Newton's
method update. So in this case,
I would have a Hessian which
would be negative, definite.
And, uh, uh, if I was to,
if I was to minimize the quadratic
approximation of that function,
say this was the quadratic approximation.
And we clearly see that in this case,
the optimum would,
would be to take the value and
increase it and an athlete.
So a, so Newton's method is only practical
if we have these two constraints.
Uh,
still there are a lot of albums.
I take inspiration from Newton's
method and, uh, try to, uh,
either not have to rely on computing
the full question and somehow make sure
that the matrix that we have
here is a still positive,
definite.
And so for that,
I encourage you to look at the recommended
readings on the course's website.
Well, you see, uh, some, uh,
examples of methods that try to correct
for these issues and get a naturally
practical logarithm for
large neural networks.